boa tarde galera eu vi a devastação
feita naquele coffee-break vocês podem
fazer bem melhor do que isso
boa tarde galera
agora sem sentir firmeza é um grupo
grande eu quero conhecer vocês melhor
pra isso preparei uma pequena dinâmica
de caráter aeróbico para fazermos agora
tranquem as portas por favor eu vou
contar até três e ao meu comando todos
vocês vão olhar pra lá e depois ao meu
comando todos vocês um olhar pra lá é
muito simples é só fazer assim e assim
alguma dúvida ótimo muito bom então
vamos começar 123 pra lá
sensacional e agora prá lá
muito obrigado desta forma eu pude ter
um perfil da platéia
é dessa forma que nós besteirologistas
fazemos anamnese é dessa forma que nós
palhaços fazemos assinante e eu não
poderia começar essa fala sem
compartilhar com vocês essas tecnologias
bobas porque dentro desse tema como uma
ideia pode mudar o mundo a minha pena a
minha ideia é transformar palhaços cada
vez mais para um futuro onde a gente
possa fazer o download de uma cultura de
alegria e quando a gente fala em palhaço
não é mesmo a qual é o primeiro lugar
que vem à mente muito bom o circo mas o
circo tem só 250 anos aproximadamente
antes do circo tinha palhaço sim ou não
500 anos atrás tinha palhaço senhor não
vai a prova viva da reencarnação isso é
muito bom
eu tô vendo que tinha muitos de vocês lá
então exatamente então eu vou pedir pra
vocês por favor voltarem no tempo para
dizer pra mim como é que nós apreciamos
a 500 anos atrás já que não tinha o
circo que nos tt nos trouxe a
característica do nariz vermelho como é
que o palhaço aparecer de que forma o
bobo da corte inteligente o suficiente
para se passar por bobos
só pra poder falar as verdades que
direcionavam a todos - a ele porque
afinal de contas ele é só um inofensivo
bobo bobo da corte menestrel comediante
de l'art saltimbanco poeta todas essas
formas de manifestação do arquétipo do
bobo eu fui aprender tudo isso porque ao
fundar o doutores da alegria e me ver
trabalhando com palhaços eu sabia ser
palhaço mas eu senti necessidade de me
aprofundar e conhecer um pouco mais da
nossa ancestralidade e foi dessa forma
que eu me deparei com esse arquétipo do
bobo e as suas várias formas de
manifestação ao longo da história da
humanidade tanto que é um arquétipo que
sempre esteve presente em todas as
etapas de evolução da humanidade
eu vou contar até três e pedir para
vocês olharem as pessoas à sua direita
olharem as pessoas à sua esquerda
perceberem as pessoas à sua volta
123 podem começar ora isso percebam
não preciso usar mal pra perceber
ninguém viu
mas se estão vendo a reação de vocês é
inevitável desde que a humanidade passou
a se juntar em bandos no meio deles
sempre tem um bobo olha em volta e aí o
que eu aprendi com os bobos justamente
qual era a função desse cara era poder
falar uma série de verdade que
normalmente as pessoas nunca gostariam
de ouvir era poder mostrar para as
pessoas principalmente os reis no poder
uma outra forma de ver o mundo e quando
a gente fala em bobo da corte qual é a
época que vem à mente idade média
exatamente mas eu aprendi que china
século 7 antes de cristo nenhum
governante se considerava completo se
ele não tivesse ao seu lado um bobo
exatamente e aí até contar um caso
específico porque nós não temos muitas
imagens daquela época na china mas a
gente tem os relatos que os escribas do
rei narravam eles escreviam todos os
diálogos que aconteciam entre o rei e
seus bobos a esse é um bobo chamado
homem que ele servia o rei william do da
região chamada que na china isso e 350
mais ou menos antes de cristo rei manhã
e tinha um cavalo branco que ele amava e
esse cavalo um dia morreu e ele então
chamou todos os militares e falou esse
cavalo era um soldado muito corajoso no
topo comigo em várias batalhas
então eu vou homenageá lo encerrando com
todas as honrarias digna de um grande
militar os militares ouviram aquilo e
falaram reino bacana mas veja bem é um
cavalo rei não é um ser humano e o rei
falou assim bom
ele era muito precioso pra mim e serviu
esse reino se vocês não gostam da minha
idéia eu vou considerar a extradição e
vou condená los à morte
e aí então os militares falaram não
precisa também pegar tão pesado e foi aí
que o bom
o dele o homem falou precisa pegar
pesado sem é isso aí meu rei tem que
mostrar pra essa galera quem é que manda
nesse galinheiro por que aliás só podia
ser militar
pra ser tão insensível assim não é mesmo
a ai meu rei eu vou dizer uma coisa
sinceramente honraria militar com esse
cavalo é pouco sutil e enterrado com
honrarias reais digna de um grande rei o
real viu isso por um segundo olhou para
o bobo e falou pensando bem joga na vala
comum mesmo eu estava só exaltado e aí
os militares respiraram aliviados e o
povo falou e pensando bem é o seguinte o
senhor queria né exaltar o exemplo desse
cavalo então por que nós não mandamos o
cavalo pra cozinha real ea então
legislação com batatas cebolas
champignons e nós todos nos reunimos em
torno de um grande banquete saboreando a
coragem deste grande cavalo
o rei falou boa idéia ea coisa acabou em
cavalo assado
então é não anunciar se existe a pizza
na época mas isso a gente conhece hoje
com o nome de empatia ele ajudou rei a
se colocar no lugar daqueles militares
então o que o pai é o que nós porque
formar palhaços é o que a gente aprende
com o bobo que a gente aprende com o
palhaço
quando você pega o arquétipo do bobo e
junta com um arquétipo do curador o
atlético do boba que manifesta palhaço
bobo da corte poeta e aí você tem um
arquétipo do curador
quando você junta esses dois arquétipos
é aí que você tem um maluco beleza por
exemplo como o xamã como o pajé carro
hum entenderam que alguém tem alguma
dúvida
eu vou aí era isso que o pai já estava
sempre fazendo nas tribos o pajé
o xamã ele estava sempre perguntando
para o povo onde está você agora
exatamente porque porque ele queria
saber se a gente estava habitando a
única certeza que a gente tem pra levar
uma vida saudável
a gente precisa tá vivendo a única
certeza que a gente conhece que é o
momento presente
agora pensem no ser humano contemporâneo
um ser humano que está sempre correndo
em direção à meta que ele tem que bater
no futuro que ainda não aconteceu então
não existe correndo atrás do prejuízo
num passado que já passou ele não vai
voltar
eu não posso mudá lo só posso aprender
com ele então se você pegar o pobre do
ser humano contemporâneo e tirar uma
foto vai sair um borrão porque ele não
está em lugar nenhum e é desse lugar
nenhum que muitas vezes esse ser humano
toma decisões que afetam impactam a sua
vida ea de todo mundo em volta e como
dizem os chineses se a gente continuar
indo pra onde a gente estamos se levando
a gente vamos chegar lá
então o pajé queria saber isso ele era
responsável pela saúde da tribo então
está tentando pra onde você está se
levando cada partida para onde vou onde
você está indo cetac agora e o que o
palhaço que o bobo
vence na para a gente a conhecer e
confiar no presente e como eles fazem
isso nos trazendo a criança a criança
que é especialista em viver no presente
na chega para uma criança fala vamos
brincar vamos então amanhã amanhã pela
manhã quando se é criança manhã é daqui
a dez anos
aí ela acorda no dia seguinte pergunta
hoje já é amanhã né então e agente
formador da apple que faz vamos brincar
agora não daqui a pouquinho só
determinar se estão vendo a gente tem os
mestres do lado da gente o tempo todo
como muitas vezes a gente não consegue
ver luz dessa forma então a criança o
palhaço o bobo eles vêm ensinar a gente
que nem tudo que você vê o que você vê a
não ter medo de ser ridículo
por isso que quando um adulto senta com
essa criança e faz um olha só havia um
enorme
nenhuma criança eu na minha vida de
falar a país é tão infantil
muito pelo contrário o que você vê a
criança fazer entrar no jogo ela fala
sim vamos brincar porque a única certeza
que a gente tem é esse momento de
alegria agora agora pega essa cena e usa
toda a sua lógica e toda sua razão para
analisar prato de papinha colher cheia
de papinha adulto coberto de papinha
fazendo um papel ridículo mas para o
nosso amiguinho ali o fato desse cara
jogar todo esse preconceito fora e ficar
inteiro nessa cena e se colocando
totalmente a serviço do encontro com
essa criatura este filho e sobrinho esse
neto que é o palhaço ensina pra gente
também
o outro é o convidado mais importante da
festa de aniversário da minha vida então
eu vou pegar tudo aquilo que eu faço a
minha vida inteira tentando esconder e
acho que consigo pelo meio ridículo vou
dar de presente pra ele pra falar
podemos brincar agora porque isso é o
que interessa
então os bobos os palhaços os menestréis
eu aprendi com eles ao longo desses anos
todos que estão toda hora lembrando a
gente da nossa humanidade toda hora
lembrando a gente da nossa capacidade de
rir de nós mesmos em primeiro lugar pra
gente poder ri com o outro porque dentro
do hospital
o que eu mais vi foi a crise que tomam
conta de um corpo a ponto de paralisar
lo ea gente não nega essa crise mas a
gente vai buscar o que está bom o que
está saudável e nós aprendemos com o
filósofo chamado espinosa que saúde não
é a ausência de doença mas a conexão com
a nossa potência para olhar nos olhos da
doença e falar vamos brincar vamos
dialogar e por que então eu insisto
fôrma palhaços no mundo de hoje porque o
arquétipo do curador é o arquétipo do
bobo
eles foram se eles foram se encontrando
ao longo da história mas um advento da
era industrial eles se separaram e foram
para extremos
o curador se tornou médico de branco o
sanitarista o higienista e o palhaço e o
menestrel e todas as suas formas de
manifestação quase vão à extinção não
fosse o circo e como um ventríloco ana
acolheu todos esses artistas no deu pra
eles conhecimento técnico refinamento e
deu pra eles também uma nova identidade
aquela com nariz vermelho e segundo a
catedrática da doutora sirena da equipe
dos doutores da alegria
há a menor máscara do mundo oculta o
nariz para revelar um ser humano
então esses artistas ficaram incubados
no circo até que em 1996 um palhaço
chamado michael christensen sai do circo
a convite de um hospital e em respeito
ao hospital ele fala como que é esse
entra aqui como que são as pessoas que
estão aqui
então como ele viu que lá é um lugar de
especialistas ele entrou como besteira o
lojista e justamente na primeira vez que
ele entrou numa uti a médica chefe falou
para ele muito legal que você faz mas é
uma uti não é lugar de criança então ele
olhou nos olhos e falou muito legal que
você faz
háháhá mas a alta e não é um lugar de
criança e ela falou assim
na verdade o que aconteceu com ela falou
muito legal o que você faz
mas eu tenho não é lugar de palhaço e aí
ele olhou pra ela e falou muito legal
que você faz
mas o time também não é lugar de criança
e foi a partir desse encontro que nasceu
um diálogo que gerou um programa de
visitas que nunca mais parou ele
acontecer por três semanas e nunca mais
parou
começou a gerar outros programas e antes
da expressão marketing viral acontecer
os palhaços que estavam se globalizando
e se vir alisando brincando com a figura
do médico
isso gerou inovações no fato de que
outros palhaços começaram a criar
programas para entrar em educação
a criar programas pra momentos de
catástrofe como por exemplo a resposta
do nariz vermelho aonde tem uma
catástrofe um grupo de palhaços se
mobilize vai trabalhar com aquelas
pessoas
então hoje a gente está vendo cada vez
mais esse arquétipo voltar a atacar
presente na vida da gente em contato com
a gente pra lembrar gente da nossa
humanidade
então por que é formar bons palhaços no
mundo de hoje porque é um mundo que está
em constante mudança constante evolução
onde a gente aprendeu muita coisa que
parecia certa mas que hoje está errado
entre a e b
hoje tem 550 tons de cinza e esse e é
esse artista é esse palhaço é esse cara
que vai pegar a gente pela mão e vai
falar tudo bem
vamo vamo dar o próximo passo vamos
junto porque assim a gente pode ir
juntos evoluir não pelo sofrimento mas a
gente pode evoluir pela alegria
então por que formavam os palhaços
porque já dizia clarice lispector na sua
crônica das vantagens de ser bobo porque
só o bobo é capaz de excesso de amor e
só o amor faz um banco muito obrigado